[Music]
joining me today is a stand-up comedy
legend
that's right legend and actor and author
and a pain in Larry David's ass Richard
Lewis I am a pain in his ass he deserted
it's a pleasure to be here
it's a beautiful studio thanks Alan this
is where the Birdman of Alcatraz tried
to kill himself when he thought his cell
what kind of room is this this was the
garage huh this was the garage and you
turn this into a student I did it look
that's legit come on you do a lot of TV
tell me this is not legit what we've got
going on in here this is pretty cool man
you know and you'll also have a tanning
booth Rick which is cool yeah is that
why you're rocking the shades I rock the
shades now because I in my I'm 70 I just
turned 70 and a light bothers me does it
bother you that it bothers me a little
bit huh a little bit I don't care yeah
at this point in my life I've done
everything I've ever wanted to do and
nothing is gonna bother me if you say
take your shades off I'd ride walk and
it'd be great PR for the show it would
be good Richard Lewis well take off
later on when I say goodbye yeah so I
don't know they don't ask me anything
you don't it starts to stumble no it's
young look I wrote some things down but
I'm gonna put it on a card you know I
called you're found in a restaurant and
a Chinese restaurant and you've called
this company and get free printing I
said to my guys right before we started
I'm gonna write a few things down but
there's no chance in hell that I'm gonna
get to any of you could talk about
anything you want I'm fearless
I really am on when I'm not concerned
about people judging me anymore yeah is
that a new that's that's not new for you
really no but I really don't care now I
mean you get to a point I'm in my in the
in the golden years you know and so now
whenever I can get concerned about what
people think I laugh at myself to go who
cares man
I'll do it and think of whatever I want
I'll take these off it's hugging you man
yeah well now I feel we can have a
deeper connection you know you mean that
I'm not happy about you don't want the
connection to forget me I'm a little
threatened by a deep connection I'm not
homophobic but I'm straight
I loved women I don't think I contact
makes you gay you know
no white contact can make okay yeah
particularly if you wink at somebody ah
alright well we'll see why are you gonna
drink water there's water here how
messed up no I wouldn't drink out of
that cuz it's already been used well my
guys are legit I mean they're not trying
to no no but I'm not saying there's
poison in it but it's already open
people put their fingers on the top of
it I don't even know why you drink out
of your own bottles this is what they
get I should question don't take this
wrong all be done you pretty much know
what asked me out really I'm ready
you're ready I got you show you're a
brilliant guy you're you're also a very
very funny comedian you're a highly
intellectual you dress like a mannequin
that wants to shoot his head off it's
okay
I was gonna do all black today but no I
don't think that would be you'd be like
a baby
good did you invent the all-black no
children all by Johnny Cash it was a TV
show when I was a kid Palin and he were
all black no I don't take credit for but
III think I hadn't been asked this years
ago and I I was so one of the
psychological reasons for getting on
stage for me because I felt so judged by
my family they weren't bad people they
were just in their own world and a lot
of them had and they were my brother and
sister were much older they were out of
the house my father was never home he
died before I went onstage that which
was sort of sad your dad was a kosher
butcher right making that sound like a
Nazi a case of butcher what did he
acoustic war on wood no way that was a
caterer he was the best
kosher caterer kosher caterer in New
York and New Jersey and Connecticut he
was the king yeah but he was never home
and a lot of bar mitzvahs I guess bar
mitzvahs weddings everything he did you
know he'd you know he wouldn't be
opposed to making money if he had like a
sweet 16 for a nun yeah but I remember I
learned an important lesson about
business yet he had a commissary that's
at about 250 people and then he would go
to hotels like New York the plaza the
you know
all of them that he was the best mm-hmm
bill Lewis ambassador kids he was the
best but never home he had to book the
parties then set up the parties he would
turn a gymnasium it's 6:00 in the
morning and by 8:00 when the wedding
happened it looked like Alice in
Wonderland he was a genius yeah and then
he would put on a tuxedo so he was there
from 5:00 in the morning set up little
help he was a big guy he had helped set
up the wedding make coordinate the
flowers the lights I'm bringing it up
for a reason
and then he would loss but he also had
to book the party so like I say a young
couple in their 30s and their kids
having a Bar Mitzvah
so a tip you can get as much as you can
out of these people like you say you
just want shrimp don't you like your son
why don't you have some sirloin tips
well the sirloin tip senate's it's $32 a
plate just the shrimp if you really you
know hey just son it's the only $18 yeah
so you know you would he would try to
get his money
what kind of silver you want plastic
spoons you know I please experience
that's free but if you get silverware
from you know from Prussia I just made
pressure up on you know if I think it
probably existed then it then yeah then
it's $100 a setting so I I didn't really
know what we was doing but I realized
that he was he was selling you know to
this young couple so I'm sitting in the
back room and he doesn't know I'm there
and he and he's telling this young
couple who was crying that for the
mothers crying my son's an idiot he
can't speak Hebrew
but Mitch was going to be a failure
we're gonna have to believe that we're
gonna be ostracized from the community
it was like I'm sitting there going my
poor bastard you know I mean I did
pretty well yeah I had a teleprompter
but still it was fine ya know so all of
a sudden I hear my father's shift gears
and I didn't understand yet he says let
me tell you something I don't know how
your son will be fine the cantor will
help him figure it out my son was the
biggest embarrassment in the history of
Judaism he didn't know one word
he didn't know whether to go left to
right right to left he was dyslexic
it wasn't Moses came down and chastised
him he just and then they started
laughing and then all of a sudden I hear
this alright so you'll get the lobster
tail so I was crying because he was
putting me down so they leave and he
sees me there I don't think it doing
that him that I heard and not any and
then he knew I said how dare you and
then he took me down to his commissary
it was very cinematic it was almost like
a square say Z bar mitzva Z and we're
sitting in this darkened commissary and
he said let me tell you what I just did
let me give you a lecture about business
and he told me exactly why he did it to
make more money and to make them feel
better and he says yes and and he it was
hard for him to I forget how we
explained how we you know humiliated me
and they used me yeah but he did but he
taught he said it in such an such a
professional way I said I get it
and then I smacked him in the face and I
never saw him again
and then you did stand up the next day
Crowley no I did stay no but the thing I
was going to say about judgment my
father was never home my mother had a
lot of emotional problems my brother of
his older than me he was out of the
house and my sister he eloped when I was
11 and she had four kids by the time I
was 16
Wow so she was gone and my mother and I
were like a bad odd couple we were not
couple yeah and so I needed to stand up
to be I needed studies that could say a
thing I I just came from a family
reunion and I'm so glad to be in front
of strangers and to throw away but
that's what I meant it
yeah I needed strangers more than family
because you know some of my relatives my
younger Neff is my nephews of my niece
big Doug uncle Richard but there were
kids but and so a handful of relatives
yeah
but most of them didn't get me they
thought I was an embarrassment I you
know I use hyperbole all you're a
comedian you know you want at one of the
things you do you know you do might when
I did Carnegie Hall I went back I was
born in Brooklyn but we moved to New
Jersey right across the George
Washington Bridge and an angle in New
Jersey
and I did my home theater which became a
venue about 2,000 seats and I said I
better do about a two-hour show a week
before Carnegie ought just to get warmed
up I was on the road a lot but I wanted
to do a show would before so it was sold
out you know a hometown boy you know and
my mother comes and she she was in some
bizarre way and I and it sounds cruel
but she was jealous because my father
was a big shot in town and then I became
a bigger shot because I was known
nationally and I think it affected her
you know was a brain it wasn't she
didn't mean harm but you know and I
would always hear from other people she
loves you but you know it was hard a lot
of people hear that oh she does I you
know maybe she can send me a letter yeah
you know I don't mean to pick on her too
much but she came to the gig in
Inglewood yeah an hour early stood in
the lobby and this is true and
introduced hi I'm Richard's mom I'm
Richard's mom I'm Blanche I'm Blanche
Lewis I'm Richard's mother
so everybody all 2,000 people knew that
it was my mother
yeah so I go on stage and I'll just say
something provocative and stupid but
let's say I said something dumb not dumb
but just so my father you know I was
jealous he had four penises my mother
stood up they all knew it was her no she
she said my husband didn't have four
penises so then the whole audience was
like on her side
yeah how dare you would say that about
your mother and father so the show took
about four hours I kept apologizing
after every joke this is like a stand-up
strewed well I called her you know she
was an actress one of those actresses
when you play in libraries and you know
I forget the community theater area and
she got fairly good at it but in the
beginning she was not but who is good in
the beginning like I once went to a show
and I'm walking gee and and in the
middle of the scene I was a little later
when you're in the third row she breaks
the fourth wall it was sort of like you
know shelling it was sort of hip mm-hmm
so I told her I called her up but she
didn't know
she loved acting and I said you can't
come to Carnegie Hall it was really a
tough call and Hailey and she said to me
she talked to me she says I'll be there
I'll be dressed in a beard I'll have a
costume on you won't know I'm there but
I'll be there was torture Wow
but she didn't come I said mother I'm a
method actor and I sort of am i studied
method acting and i said i'm a method
comedian whatever hits me at the moment
i just go there yeah doesn't mean it's
gonna be any good but that's who I am
and if I'm feeling you in that room yeah
the whole two hours or whatever it was
and it was two hours and it was a great
night would have been changed so she
didn't come and it was you know it was a
great night
wow there's no that was a tough call
yeah but there's a lot there about
souville I don't remember what the
question was but but that's a lot if I
sent you the email about the question
God so I had to bring it up but he goes
- so I watched this morning so I watched
it I literally watched I think when I
was six years old or five years old
1981 young comedians special watching
you and you're on with with Seinfeld and
Howie Mandel overton yeah I know I know
we know hosted at the The Smothers
Brothers yeah but I always tease
smothers about it because I destroyed
that night yeah and there's a there's a
fun if we ever get to it I'll tell you
there's an amazing Carson story about
that monologue no actually this was
about a drugstore I did and it was so
strong I'm just saying yes I mean it was
I bombed a million times no you crushed
you've had Tommy said God he is just I
was I wasn't suggesting and I'm not was
say the word genius but he was going to
say something really of hyper worldly of
high praise and then he cut himself off
and I remember watching a news Sun and
he once told me because I'm an alcoholic
recovering for almost 24 years now and
his brother's sober Dickie and Tommy
went so I was assortment in Airport once
and Tommy says yeah you and your book
you're my brother read your book about
alcoholism I drink for both of us
that's maybe they were alleged there
talk about legend you should get them on
the show boy yeah they did for first and
man what friends I know I know that you
yeah well know so what the reason I want
to talk about that moment was because I
watched so I've watched the whole
special I watched your set again this
morning and you know when you watch it
so you got Seinfeld you know who some
say is the greatest stand-up of all time
you got how he made over the Raiders
stand above all done I mean it's Carlin
for me but you're in my top ten but no
writer for a lot he's a different he's
an observational comedian
you can't put anybody in the class with
Jonathan winners and Lenny Bruce and and
Mort soil and Richard Pryor you can yeah
talk about some of the respect to Derry
and anybody else none of those guys you
know they came first they were more
brilliant than anybody else and I have a
lot of stories about witches who was a
surrogate father to me and Phyllis
Diller but and you know Jerry is one of
the hardest-working comedians in any and
use you know Larry and him you know
change the generation no but when you
just talk about pure stand up ya know ya
know it's Lenny Bruce and prior and
Carlin and yeah and you put labels ma
and Mel Brooks and call Ron how can you
compare anybody to any but do those guys
I saw years ago they did Comedy Central
did that list where they listed they had
they had you on it I don't remember
where I do 40 you were 40 40 tonight
then I looked at the list I went I can
name 20 people that have morons but it's
all [ __ ] because times changed you
know but so I was watching that special
with you and even though I did blow up
the list and put it over my bed and I
had it of course to it that I have
someone laughing love them they're
laughing back there keep it down wait
let me just get this one point now you
can talk all you want just one point
across which is so I watched that
special and if you watch all of all of
the other guys are kind of they're just
doing stand-up but when I watched it
even this morning again it was like it's
what you said before about the way you
do it it's just like you just got up
there it was like I couldn't even tell
if you were acting or not you know what
I mean like wasn't this stand-up or was
this just some guy getting up there and
talking about his [ __ ] and it it's
something else like it's actually
something else and I think it's awesome
I listen so that's it I want to say well
no no thanks someone call me and say
some guy will we know in the business no
I know what it was it was all for the
Jimmy Kimmel show and they would you
know I had lived most of it but I had
something you know some bullets in my
head you know nice phrase you know some
material but I said you know don't ask
me what I'm going to say because I don't
know I have been doing this 49 years you
can ask me about his shirt about God
about Jesus about Muslims about you know
coca-cola all I can go forever I'm not
saying it's going to be funny but don't
ask me good we can talk about the old
days and the talk shows and how there's
a lot of interesting stuff for comedians
at least and how they prepare you and
they want you know what are you gonna
talk about and all that crap you know
it's it's such I know I have that's an
interesting area if we ever get to it
but someone said to me says someone said
it was a nice it was a it was nice I
felt good he says he says you were funny
and some of the stuff was hilarious and
Kimmel was dying and he gave you another
ten minutes he says but it sounded as if
you had no idea that it was going to
come out of your mouth and it was it
seemed all that live and I said well it
wasn't all ad-lib I knew an area but I
don't know how to stay on I know that A
to B to C I used to be jealous of
comedians and then let me just get back
to Jerry for a minute you know he's my
one of my best friends you know made
everyone he made everyone billionaires
Jerry N and Larry yeah and Jerry was
equally as responsible you know it was
his show but these are the kind of guys
and I did a lot of specials five or six
or seven specials and then you got to go
on the road and you do about 60 or 70
minutes of the same material that you
think is your finest and then you narrow
it down and you try to get 55 minutes
and that's the special after a while I
couldn't take it
but Seinfeld is one of those guys who is
if not one of the
at being in the trenches and taking
every word and making sure every word
count the the greatest of all is George
Carlin who was a buddy of mine and I
used to and I mean I'm flipping around a
little bit I would but I like to ad-lib
I stopped doing specials in 97 I went I
just want to free associate and I have
thousands of pages of material I'll
never get to it but I go on the road I
used to bring notes on stage now I'm
really going all over the place tonight
Carnegie Hall Vegas specials even the
specials you know I would have about
four hours of new material I never said
it before and to me that was cool I said
people that were fans of mine which I
imagined this it was all [ __ ] in my
head
boy Lewis doesn't even know if it's
funny and he's gonna do it
so if let's say it was a bit about let's
say I had 30 jokes on the circus the
Lewis Circus yeah it would say Lewis
Circus but it would take me months to
get it to the sheets of paper which had
four hours of material I would look down
for a second and my eyes would see 30
lines I could pop up and do at least 20
circus jokes no it's back then I loved
writing one-liners you know one line
like Woody Allen was maybe the greatest
one-line Geibel he was like a jeweler
mm-hmm you know yo you know you set up
the premise plus he had the the good
fortune of having that persona that
looked like him and he had the great
punchline
the premise is what's most important if
you don't have a good premise it doesn't
matter what the punchline is because the
premise is what the gold is you know you
know now I'm Way all over the joint and
I'm sorry I don't even know where I was
gonna go yeah you want to kick me off
the show no I want you to let's see what
happens now no god that's all the
material yeah so I always thought it was
cool that I didn't that I was going to
come onstage let's let's say caroline's
which by the way I'm playing around
Europe for the fortieth year I saw you
at Caroline's once and you about ten
years ago and I think you just had a
yellow pad and we were about 10 years
ago I stopped so maybe maybe a little
before that yes yeah and I had a piano
it was a pen yes like in Vegas once I
had a pen
bigger than Elton John's and the
Teamsters was lifting this 3,000 ton
piano and I had about four sheets of six
feet long yellow paper with all five
hours of material never said before okay
Vegas ladies and gentlemen Richard Lewis
the MGM wherever I was I mean it takes a
lot of balls let me just say that if I
may say so yeah
because I was bored I said I if I can't
say how I'm feeling right now or do new
material what's the point of doing this
I'd rather look at someone's gums and be
a hygienist and then kill myself lately
bleeding gums so I told the team says
they would say mr. Lewis I said call me
Richard please we never knew you played
piano I gotta play piano I have no
talent
and I just write dumb a comedian he says
yeah but why the piano I go oh no and
then I took out four sheets of paper I
just I just want to put the paper and
they almost killed me
they chased me out it was like a mother
movie this son of a [ __ ]
Justina for them got hernias yeah I mean
it was a gigantic piano but then when I
did like nightclubs I used to have on my
rider a three by four foot wooden table
it has to be six feet high - it was such
a pain - yes yeah that I said you know
screw this and then one manager I had
every manager you can name in every
agent now I just have a couple of good
agents no more managers I manage my own
life now and and he said why don't you
do it the traditional way just go
onstage and hold the mic I go why I said
this is all new material
isn't that cool I mean you know isn't
that cool
yeah but it's a work in progress I went
exactly yeah isn't that doesn't that
make me like sort of pretty cool and hip
I don't know if I'd use those stupid
words but he says yeah but audiences
expect you to be prepared when I don't
care so then I then it dawned on me it
does look like a work in progress and
they are paying 25 bucks in a two-drink
minimum and eating the Jerry Lewis Thai
salad and then the ad
sandé the frozen chicken so I said wait
a minute
maybe he's right so I stopped using the
notes and here's what happened my
performance level skyrocketed because I
had absolutely no idea what I was going
to say and I would spend hundreds of
hours before I got to the venue in my
hotel suite rooms I'm sorry I said suite
and I would just spend I would like I'd
get up at 6:00 in the morning
the shows at 8 o'clock at 11 o'clock I
would order room service and I would
look at thousands of premises and pray
that some would stick to my brain yeah
so that's all you were trying to do is
just get him like thrown against the
wall hope that by the time you get up
there all right when I stop using the
sheets and no piano and I just came out
like a regular old fashion comedian
which I sort of dug anyway yeah you know
but to bring it back about about Jerry
Seinfeld here's a guy in like Harlan and
Colin I used to call me the Rob I used
to call him the preacher now Colin wrote
his shows like plays and in some degree
a lot of guys like Jerry make sure that
they have their 50 minutes from A to Z
I'm pretty certain because they want it
they know and they get onstage I mean
I'm sure they ad-lib and they die on
occasion but but it's that pretty much
like a typewriter it's a typewriter yeah
and Colin wood was really the greatest
at this because he wanted to make sure
every word counted like Jerry and others
like Jerry yeah but Colin I would call
it go and just say you had to do he did
like about 20 specials I mean how's it
coming he says I need a minute and 12
seconds I went George don't scare me
he's is why I'm going on tomorrow night
it's what are you doing I don't know
what I'm doing and he needs a minute and
12 seconds and he was right yeah because
he knew exactly what time he was going
to end so I used to be jealous of like
comics I don't mean to be too
provocative like I'd get to a gig say
st. Louis and I'd get there and I'd have
dinner and I'd have my notes and my
sheets and I'd be looking at him and
they knew exactly when they'd get there
that have a lobster they
hooker you know then they would go on
stage there you go they hey how are you
so anyway these socks of mine are
killing me and I go you know what let
them do that that's just now that's good
for them and you know inside felt shows
or magnificent I don't mean to just like
I guess what people like Jerry yeah they
do that they know what they're doing it
must make them feel more confident and
it's and they're and they're slicker you
ever see a comedian the documentary that
Jerry did after the show went off the
air did you ever see it no so there's a
great moment where Jerry and Shandling
are riding in the car I mean yeah the
comics and cars no no he did a
documentary called comedian right after
oh no I did see a lot of it yeah yeah
there's a great moment where he and
Shandling are driving in the car and
Jerry Shandling's driving Jerry's got
his notes and it's just what you said
it's a typewriter every word looks to
shelling and he's like what do you got
it Gary he pulls out this like crumbled
piece of paper and he's like I don't
know what I'm gonna do yeah very much
that's just I'm not sure Gary worked
that way all the time but uh he would be
more prone to do that yeah then Jerry
would be yeah but there's nothing wrong
with how people like Scifo work because
it's like a Broadway play you know if
you saw Hamilton like if I was a
blinking and not Daniel day-lewis they'd
much rather see Daniel day-lewis than me
go for score and how many years is a
they'd walk out yeah so you know there's
a there's a good reason for both yeah
and I'm glad that I free associated
because when I'm doing material that's
familiar I'd say a routine and there's a
great story if we ever get to it about
the DMV and I did it for like ten years
when I was at the DMV huh
right but this is great but i but i but
it was a routine joke joke joke joke but
even when I had that I would still if I
was if I was talking about the line in
the DMV I would be able to say and
everyone's doing a dosey doe they're
doing the hora
you know I would I would at least feel
fresh that way yeah but I still had the
routine so I did it for about 6 or 7
years and it would killed and it was
about 6 minutes long and I was already
on The Tonight Show so I'm gonna do the
DMV and I said when I do this I hope it
goes over and I said but when I do this
tonight on Johnny I am I'm gonna burn
this like a witch like a Wiccan yeah
that's the same thing probably the mail
which is is it a wiki and I think I I
think you're dead wrong I think you I
think you're a [ __ ]
yeah and you were very snow it's not my
they gave me the thumbs down over there
we've been giving me all this credit no
a Wiccan is a wig what's the oh no a
warlock is a male witch okay right now
I'm humiliated being sitting on this
show we're not with Barris myself a
Wiccan is a witch but III think it's a
Wiccan that sits in a chair that has
wicker furniture so it can put a hex on
somebody sitting by a pool having a
martini I don't I could be way wrong
about that oh yeah I just said that too
even though it's an old altar cocktail
we can care guys so back in the day
there used to be a tough really tough
the town coordinator on The Tonight Show
and a really tough guy and I have a
million Carson stories but this is the
one I like the best and I used to go to
the Improv and tape it I always had I
taped every show and then I would listen
to every show because I would write
hundreds of material after six shows
like in a city I'd listen to every show
then I would write off of the joke and
write new jokes but it was so it just
took me forever I stopped doing that one
day no more I'm gonna live existentially
I'm just gonna do this show let them
laugh I don't care if I because I used
to get obsessed on what was that great
joke that joke man about the dog that
had a skull cap on and then and I had it
on tape I would listen to it and I have
it but I couldn't take it anymore I
didn't want to listen to me again I
couldn't bear I hated myself oh yeah all
right so I'm doing I I'm doing this bit
routine so here's the deal you go to the
Tonight Show you go to the talent car
he comes to see says I like it you'll do
the DMV fine if it's five minutes and I
knew him back then it's five minutes and
nine sixty and sixty five minutes and 48
seconds perfect that's what usually we
do six minutes or less yeah so then I
would tape it I come bring me the tape
let me hear it
fine go back to the / Bank here's the
tape you listen all right sounds great
so I said so far so good
I do it again bring back the tail Jesus
come on I've been doing this for 10
years since New York let me just hear it
one more time
I'd do it again all right fine you're
not their guy you know I'm on Thursday
it's like it's Tuesday so I'm really
excited up I can't wait to get rid of
this damn beam it was a great bit I must
say was hilarious and this was gonna be
it you were burning it down after that
this was oh no I was never do it again
yeah because when you start out as a
comic your goal is to get five or six
clean monologues so when the Tonight
Show people come they know not only are
you good for one great one but you're
good for like a year
yeah so that's what I did and then you
know and then when I did let them and
you can get a little more provocative
and I and the stories about every every
host but let's just talk about Johnny
about this thing I'm on stage and
generally speaking my audience is not
great in Burbank okay and our studio
audience I'm a little more kerouac than
Liberace yeah if that makes any so I'm
on stage I know what I'm doing by now
I'm a comic for 15 years can't wait to
get rid of this monologue and they're
screaming and you're a commune you know
this as well as anybody you're wait for
the laughs to dip and then you move on
yeah you don't just trample over laughs
so I do a joke so I'm at the DMV and
blah blah blah so I just stand our way
for the laughs to dip and then I go into
the next line so I'm about midway
through the DMV bit and the stage
manager goes under the camera and tells
me to wrap it up and Carson is over
there with Doc who
good buddy of mine and Carson Hill
thought I was nuts and he liked me for
that reason probably more than anything
and I said to myself it was like it was
like an automatic Joe Namath uh know it
and what am I going to do we're on the
third you're on you know it's right of
passage and I said if I get off now
the monologue sucks there's no ending I
have half of it left I'll never get the
Tonight Show again if I finish the
monologue I'll never get to the night
show again because it'll be the longest
monologue in history and they'll never
let me on again they won't get they
won't understand it but I'll say I said
to myself this is all and what in a
flash in my head I'm on television ten
million people back then I'm watching
I'm saying I rather tell people how come
me out on Johnny anymore I was too good
I said I'd rather say I was too good
than not so I finished the monologue
okay it's 11 minutes the longest
monologue has to be yeah in history I
walk backstage I'm with the two agents
and a girl I was one of the waitresses
from the improv I they were fantastic
you're gonna get that yeah great great
chick she came with me with the two
agents the agents were clueless they
went you did two monologues at one of it
you don't get it I'm dead I knew well
more than they knew and then the town
coordinator who was a tough guy he went
you will never do this show again and I
knew I was screwed so then we I always
used to go to the palm and the old palm
in Santa Monica on Santa Monica
Boulevard after every TV show it just
was like something I wanted to do I
didn't have much money you get four
eight six hundred dollars for the
Tonight Show you give 90 to the manager
they give 60 to the agent and the
government takes 39% I did The Tonight
Show would you make I'd made a dollar 90
so it wasn't about the money was about
you know getting gigs in Vegas and
specials and all that you know there so
the guy says you're never doing the
Tonight Show again I wasn't surprised so
I go to the Palm
sitting there with my date and the two
agents and they're all happy I'm like I
want I'm smacking myself with the steak
like I wanted to kill myself and the
girl who was an actress she understood
that I was screwed and she at least
understood so I turned to my left and I
see Johnny Carson still in stage makeup
like I was and then you don't remember
we shot in Burbank with a you know and
this was in Santa Monica or near Santa
Monica it was in Beverly Hills he's
there with his famous attorney we used
to call the bombastic bombastic Bushkin
they were having dinner without even
thinking I said this this was like you
know I'm not I'm a spiritual guy but I'm
not deeply religious but this was a
religious moment this was an epiphany I
said this Carson and he just saw me an
hour and a half before I dart over to
him and you know he was he get startled
I got on my knees and the lawyer you
know it was like you know I I didn't I
don't think I've met him I actually got
to know him a little bit he wrote a book
on Carson which was pretty hard-hitting
to put it mildly
yeah and at any rate forget the book I
said I got on my knees and said Johnny I
beg of you hear me all right
I said I did this monologue for 10 years
it was 5 minutes and 47 seconds I was
killing you're sitting 20 feet away with
Doc and they told me to wrap it up I'm
gonna make a fool of myself in front of
Johnny Carson and end a monologue
halfway through there's no way I'm gonna
humiliate myself you're a comic I'm a
comic you had I have to let you know I
had to finish it anyway no I hear you I
hear you
I get a call the next morning at 10:00
you're a lucky man you got the show job
if he wasn't at that restaurant I
guarantee you I don't know what would
have happened in my career I would have
let them in whatever but other things
would have happened you don't know
about life but if I probably never would
have gotten back in that office and seen
him I probably would have tried to break
through or God through him somehow but
who knows yeah
well the fact that he was there was and
I ran over to him like I used to use
this image and I hate repeating anything
even when people don't even know like
Jack Ruby I ran over to him like he was
obvious because he was like right you
know I scared the [ __ ] out of Carson
yeah and I've had many times with Carson
flying with him and doing crazy things
but this was the most important moment
of my career because he understood and
that made me feel so great how many
guards were really with me that night I
love that you told that story because
everyone tells the that you always hear
the standard story about Carson like if
you do the set and then he liked you and
you sat down then you're good to go or
if he didn't like it you didn't but you
had something crazy happen and then he
so happens to be there your problem was
that you were getting too many laughs I
mean that's actually it's like right
ultimate existential dilemma exactly
Ryan exactly right and I watched quickly
I flew to I was with a woman one of my
girlfriend I got married I met my wife
20 years ago it's a great marriage and
we got married in 205 or something we
don't care about dates and I can tell
you love this one because I saw you
remember I saw you about a year ago at
the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame and you
even gave your wife a nice shout out at
the end of that and the way you just did
there was just something I wish spoke
about her and I gave his Beach yeah well
you said that if I was at the you were
interviewed by the guy at the rock oh
yeah I was an interesting night we were
mostly talking about music and your love
of jazz and stuff like yeah yeah you're
all but well but you gave her a shout
out and it was just very you know I got
married at 57 and I found the right
woman at the right time and I never
thought I would and she found the right
guy at the right time so who was it I'm
very happy and but I'm flying with his
ex-girlfriend of mine back in the
mid-80s and she was she was very she was
she knew a lot of people in Vegas and
you know and and one of the guys that
she knew I was the only guy he liked and
allowed me to date her I think it was an
ex-husband
was a great guy mm-hmm he liked me yeah
well you either like me I would have
been in my car would have blown up yeah
but a lot of guys in there I helped
raise our daughter who I love and we're
still friends
and he says Richards the only guy you
ever went out with after me you know
which is extra our ex-husband so I was
an alcoholic back then full-blown and
we're going to Europe I had no money to
go out and a how it why or how so we're
on a plane going to New York and I was
and Johnny always went to Wimbledon he
went to Wilmington London I was gonna go
to Paris first and then whatever it
doesn't matter so we're waiting in the
first-class
oh we're flying to New York for us to
wait to our place he's gonna go to Paris
and I'm going know Wilmington yeah ain't
London and I'm gonna go to Paris and I
have a lot of nervous tics and
tremenjous not so far today but I used
to have a lot of like this and there's
Anderson so Johnny's sitting over here
I'm in the center row it was like a
center row and here's like your Carson
yeah and I could help myself I have
obsessive-compulsive disorder I had no
it wasn't Tourette's which is a horrible
disease and I'm on the board I don't
have tourettes but I feel very horrible
about these people and these kids who
have to go through and be bullied and so
I've done what I can for that charity
and so anyway so you're Carson and my
ex-girlfriend since she was a doll she
was sitting next to me but she was she
was she was vague at very Vegas too
because she was married to a Vegas guy
who read and built one of the hotels so
she was sort of a tough cookie too so
you know so she didn't you know suffer
fools gladly is that the phrasing so I'm
like this I'm sitting it's six hour
flight five hour flight and I go like
this to Carson and you know you can look
uncomfortable
yeah so then I gotta and I go every
three minutes six hour flight
staring at him okay yeah the guy's
either vomiting or laughing yeah so my
ex-girlfriend goes if you continue to
stared Carson your [ __ ] careers over
my god I know I can't help it
she says don't stare at him again I said
I can't help she's already got a Jones
for him or didn't know I love Jones all
my ideas that can't help staring it's
Johnny
yeah and I had done the show maybe I was
gonna say was this before but now I've
done it many times yeah and you know I
was nuts but he didn't know I was this
nuts yeah so I'd do this again for the
fifteenth hundredth time we get to the
lounge and he's having a drink and I'm
having a drink he's with one of his
wives I think there's a matter which and
I go Johnny he goes yeah he's like and
this is after the DMV thing too I got it
so he already knows I should be in a
hospital so I go over to him I go Johnny
you don't have to believe this I'm
[ __ ] nuts and he starts to giggle a
little bit I'm nuts I drink a lot I'm
crazy I love you the show means the
world to me
I have a lot of nervous tics and tremors
I'm a madman I didn't want to stare at
you there was no reason to stare it
wasn't love I couldn't help myself so we
started laughing so I go on the show in
about a month and the guy wants me to
tell the story about staring at Carson
on panel because at that time I was
before I did anything but love which
then I did panel all the time huh it's
then you had to have a show or a movie
and then there's others there's too much
to talk about about the world of comedy
but in this case I did the story and it
felt so great because I killed with the
story because people like you know when
you watch comics tell stories and it's
planned you know you know you know and
but this was you know a way I talk and
ramble like with you yeah it seemed you
know like I was just saying it for the
first time I knew what the story was but
Carson was laughs in the end when and
when the audience left it sort of it
validated the fact that yeah they'll
blame Richard he's nuts and when when
Johnny would laugh they
laughs if you didn't laugh you might as
well you better run yeah because you're
gonna be stoned and pillaged if you can
even be pillaged by itself when you see
all this prepackaged [ __ ] that's on TV
now and how stiff it's all become
because there aren't guys that go on
these shows that much anymore like you
know it's a shame the way Charles Grodin
I did know many Letterman's yeah were
you number one or maybe was a Brenner
you know be like the render for Carson
he's the harvest Carson - Brenna for
number one easy yeah and Joan Rivers
right up there but I started doing panel
on Carson before I had my series a lot
of them because I was better on panel
and this is interesting I think because
when Johnny wasn't there
they didn't care what you did that you
know the producers didn't care yeah so
like when Joan Rivers or Gabe Kaplan
even or Brenner was my best friend and
in others when I would say you know what
I'll go on with Brenner and do panel
because it was I was you know what I
didn't want to do stand-up anymore and
this is a really important thing I want
to shout out to in 1982 this is I had
already done Carson in 74 to give you
some idea how long I've been around car
let him and Doug me and we weren't great
friends you know he's you know he's you
know he's a an authentically unique guy
okay but he dug my craziness in a way -
he invited me over to his office and he
says I want you to move to New York and
write for the show and he might not
remember this but I know you don't
forget this you can still be you know do
stand-up I don't know is he could have
given me bits to do on the show and
everything I said I just moved out here
years ago III can't move back to New
Year once I left I left I came out to LA
to make it you know he said I get it I
get a breeze but I gotta tell you
something I see you on Johnny and I did
let him and when I and I panel only oh -
because he was the host yeah and I he
says you're too physical for the camera
the cameras like this and I'm going all
over the place in fact let
one said he was so physical you left the
screen dude he said to me yeah but
that's what I loved about that 81
especially your darting across the stage
yeah but you can't do for Jack Benny
here's an exact penny that's the perfect
examples that for television stand up
yeah you don't move but if you're going
like this you look at matures and Johnny
knew that and I knew that so let him in
new at to let him in the snow so
brilliant he says you could do my show
and this is a quote as often as you want
anytime you want to do it you do it but
never stand up I don't want you to do
stand up only panel and that was 1982 ok
and I was in my early you know early
thirties and and and from that point on
I never did stand up on television again
ever
only panel and they when they would call
me from shows all right I'll do five
minutes no no and my publicist now he
doesn't do stand-up on TV what do you
mean no no he doesn't do it ask cold
Dave yeah and I never did it again so he
really because I was just you know
twitching around and the you know on the
chair and you know and that was I was
better that way now when I did specials
on HBO
you know he's sure you're moving around
but the cameras farther back well the
cameras right in your face and you're
doing this and that and yeah you know so
anyway Dave David really I had a lot of
breaks I'll just give you this one quote
yeah Sid Neelam ed one of the great
directors in history and he worked with
a billion actors and I just saw a
documentary on Lynette and he said he
worked with every famous actor you can
imagine and he said the one word he
heard mostly from actors and again a
good would be for comics ballerinas
comedy writers is luck of course you got
to work on your craft when that when the
luck happens you better be ready cuz it
doesn't come around that often but luck
and and I had luck
I had Letterman say no more stand-up I
had Carson understand my craziness I
auditioned for Jamie Lee Curtis who says
you're my guy and even though I had a
fight I had a fight with some executives
at ABC at the time
John Ritter love me yeah and I was
auditioning with a couple of other
actors and this is a true story and I'll
Ben I'm proud to say it and I said he
says Jamie wants you he was a producer
of the show he was a producer one of
them I want you xx one shoot this
there's a handful of one or two people
that aren't sure about you at ABC and
Ritter was a god yeah see yeah and he
came out and wasn't anything about the
other actors but they loved me yeah but
but you'd still got to be hired by the
network so he went in to the network he
says to them and this is true he says I
am NOT leaving the studio until Lewis is
Jamie Lee's co-star no [ __ ] I had no
idea he was even and I told that to his
son who's a wonderful actor and I said I
want you to know how important your
father might have made my career because
all of a sudden I went from nightclubs
to selling out 3,000 Cedars and making a
ton of money unfortunately I was an
alcoholic and I spent way too much and
gave way too much away but you know what
I'm with you now I'm sober 23 and a half
years and I'm a lucky guy so I had luck
I had and then the greatest luck of all
night in 2000 I read David comes over
because I've done a lot of I've done
enough dramatic stuff that I dig it I
did a movie called drunks when I was a
year sober
it's a terrific independent movie with
and I got the role like I wish inand got
it yeah and I did like I did a scene in
leaving Las Vegas and this made me feel
excited because I knew I had I'm not
gonna do you know Shakespeare but I can
I have a range but I was typecast you
did was type K so I'm not complaining
how do I've had a Grice time with you
I'm so you know I'm curb is coming back
for its ninth year I'm a lucky cat you
know but the thing is Larry came over my
house and said do you want to play
yourself because he says he knew that it
would pretty much bury me as an a
dramatic actor right I'm playing me yeah
imagine me we've been getting an Emmy
and winning at me Richard Lewis playing
himself hasn't
so for himself by himself not gonna hand
I don't care about winning I'm just glad
I'm on a great show
yeah but Lowry says you couldn't be my
best friend on the show and like we are
you know you know best friends in odd
ways but you know we love each other
yeah and he said to me I said I'll do
the show but I have one condition and it
took a little balls up some balls to do
this because to work with Larry David
you know come on this is two years at
the Seinfeld and I said I do not want to
do a cameo you know he says I'm doing 10
shows I said fine I'm not gonna be like
that famous like say Sammy Davis jr. on
right on all in the family
well there's Richard lower these your
pharmacist right well I put me you don't
even have an applause track for them to
start laughing yeah whatever I said I
got to do at least three shows yeah I
want to be judged on at least three he
gave me three or four and the reviews
for the show were ridiculous and I got I
did well yeah with me and him as a as
sort of a best friends yeah and he knew
it was it like that with the two you
when you when you were on camera
together because now you see it and the
way you say me like it's just there's
despise each other for the same reasons
on and off camera but we care about each
other we respect each other immensely I
must say I'm proud of that we trust each
other I would do I would on a dime I
would stop and do anything for him and I
love his daughters and you know we're
just great friends it's just he's so
he's so unusual he's so bizarre and so
and he always says to me and people have
asked him this he says I wish I was more
like the Larry David on curve and I said
what about me says well you're you're
like you but I put you in such
heightened situations you're crazier
yeah I go you know i said it's true but
he is he's really would rather be the
real obnoxious you know don't tell me
how to live and don't do that i mean he
doesn't hang he's much calmer that way
in real life you know he's not a
confrontational guy at all yeah you know
and but on the show he's he's
you know you know crazy crazy
confrontational and Van hilarious but
you know he's just a very odd guy and I
accept it you know I we would eat called
me once we only see each other make once
or twice a year because I have to share
my feelings to anyone a busboy a nice
busboy at Denny's hi how are you I hope
you get out of here soon and get a good
job by the way I have a rash right about
here
we're not even taping this I was just
yeah I knew you liked to talk to people
so I got well yeah yeah I know
yeah but Larry asked me to dinner once
and I asked him I know I did mention
this once but I it's just your audience
might not know I said what time you want
dinner he says 411 no what do you say I
just had pizza it's lunch said I want
dinner and I need her to eat early I
said not having dinner at 4:11 he says
all right 503 this went on for an hour
on the phone I mean this is who he is
yeah so he goes to this high you know
this big shot that he's not a big shot
he's he's so down to earth but he's an
odd duck you know so we go to this
famous restaurant in Beverly Hills
Chinese restaurant pretty restaurant I
and we're supposed to meet at 513 513
like some psychotic Jewish what do you
call those guys in the boos at the
airport you know a traffic of Java
before yeah the only Jewish child so I
get there an hour early because I want
to pay the check
just because he's so loaded doesn't mean
I have bread I don't
so I tell the maitre d hey mr. Lewis
nice to see you oh yeah it's nice to see
you listen I'm gonna pay the check for
Lowry and I oh no no no you can't pay
for mr. David but I'm gonna let me tell
you something I've been doing this for
49 years I'm paying the check no you
can't yes I am I'm treating Lowry I mean
this is an episode of curve
yeah of course I said we were born in
the same hospital room I could treat him
and we were three days apart is that
right yeah and so he comes an hour late
he comes at 6:03 I remember these dates
because he's a mental case
yeah so we get there and I say why don't
we do what we did to the old
we're broke like after the in probably
go to a Chinese restaurant I'd get soup
we'd split it you get I'd get you'd get
string beans
I get the beef get the chicken of course
it's $8 we split it because what are you
crazy
because he's not a phony at all yeah but
I said what do you mean says I'm not
going to embarrass the chef embarrass
the chef what do you mean he says he'll
tell us what we should eat go party
you're telling me I have to listen to
the chef he says he's a famous chef he's
world renowned I said I want to eat what
I want no no I'm whatever he brings us
he brings 20 entrees in a lazy susan 20
entrees okay and I'm pissed off already
cuz I'm there for three two hours early
yeah and the phone rings we haven't even
had a discussion and it's Steve Martin
and it and I mean and he goes Steve
what's up oh my god forgot hangs up
doesn't say goodbye to me he goes it's
poker night and leaves me there with a
30 that bastard that's son of an I told
the way to give this to it give this to
charity I'm not taking out five hundred
it's like a muscle man [ __ ] I know
you've got some dough but you're not in
the Larry David billionaire clown 1304 a
lunch seems a little excessive wait
before I might have made that figure up
I add so I interviewed you my mom showed
up no dude I interviewed you once when I
was on SiriusXM years ago on the phone
and I asked you this question and I
wonder if you're gonna give me the same
exact answer because I know you don't
can any of this stuff were there any
guys when you were in that those years
of stand-up that you thought were like
gonna be the legends that just
disappeared that disappeared yeah the
ones that didn't make cuz I know from
from when I was doing Santa some of the
guys that I thought were the best kind
of disappeared and some of the guys that
I thought were pretty shitty or just
generic they're actually the ones that
are on TV know somethin let me answer in
a more general way because I have mine I
don't like to name names yeah I just you
know well this would be giving credit to
somebody that disappeared no but I can't
even remember there was
yeah I I will say this the luck factored
you know well that's why I wanted to ask
you the thing that is most disturbing is
that people that aren't talented in
terms of better than others
get a sitcom and become very successful
and people are paying to see them and
they're and they're lightweights that
was always something that I never had I
never was
I never you know faulted them for their
luck but I said when you know I I was I
was one of the good ones back in the 70s
would you know crystal and Leno and and
Boosler and Kaufman it wasn't that many
of us really and I said what am I gonna
get my break and it took 16 years yeah
to really get a big break
I saw Simon well and she was she was
saying how everyone says she's an
overnight success and she's like where
the [ __ ] were you in the last 30 years
you know oh no yeah following hers and
JB they would we would tour together for
a while yeah they're very blue yeah you
think it's easy I'm in the wings and JB
smooths on and it goes alright so I
[ __ ] the goat good night everybody
I can't come out and do a you know a
Robert Frost really I gotta come right
out of a cannon same thing with with
Susie Essman you know she's so funny
yeah I'm design you know I was on you
know who the Muppets on there on Sesame
Street they chose me P for [ __ ]
one good night everybody
Richard Louis you know so I you know I
it's a crazy field yeah - crazy field
where where does the peace come from you
does it come from sobering up cuz I yeah
cuz because even though I know you can
have your Twix
you know you're huge is and all that
stuff but I mean literally for however
long we've been sitting here I actually
sense a lot of peace in you now thank
you which is kind of you know I've never
met you before I I you know I love and
admire you but I don't know you this way
and I sense
Pisan you I wouldn't throw that word
love around to hood by TMZ might pick it
up right we don't wanna know I'm just
kidding I know about three or four years
ago I got to the point and a lot of it
has to do with you know getting into my
mid 60's I said if I'm not gonna feel
good about what I've accomplished and
what I've overcome particularly my my
alcoholism and you know not having the
most support you know growing up or
people believing in me or thinking I
could do this you know and I did not you
know and I don't really right I don't
meet the Reg on my mother but she didn't
get it and when someone doesn't get it
and they're watching you on TV they're
embarrassed they're embarrassed and I in
Ireland this is and I wrote this in my
book the other Great Depression but when
I called it from Sunset Strip and told
the ROM on Johnny Thursday she literally
said who else is on so if that doesn't
dig a hole in your soul that you have to
overcome it takes a long time yeah but
it is you my mom it was but it was me it
was you know I was riddled with fear
it's a tough business you know you know
you know the you know you hear the you
know 5% of people make you know a living
in the arts you know when people come
over to me and say you know I'm gonna
you know I'm this I'm that I go you know
you better be patient you better just
love what you do because no one owes us
a dime you know to go out there and do a
pirouette you know you know really I
mean really don't no one knows you know
for me to write a joke about you know
Donald Duck yeah you know no one owes me
a dime so you better be you better be a
good duck joke you know and you know a
lot of people that young the younger
generation because there's so many
venues now in so many platforms and you
know it takes people like yourself to
rise above of majority I'm not just
stroking you but it's just so many I
mean I get cause because I tweet and I'm
a people pleaser and I go remember you
said you fell off your roof with that if
they got better you would I have a
podcast will fly you to
to Afghanistan and I feel badly saying
no and I hate lying but i but I know
he's the PISA came from finally owning
up to the fact that I've accomplished
what I wanted to accomplish and a lot of
this sounds very elitist but I've met
iconic people that I grew up as a child
our best friends with wood Sid Caesar
and Mel Brooks and and Ringo Starr I met
my wife through a Beatle I mean it
doesn't get any crazier they're just
people yeah but I grew up watching them
you know I you know I'm a friar by the
way and I was before I fell off my roof
I was doing Caroline's and I was
bringing my notes with me and I said you
know I'm sick of tired of this I've been
a friar 35 years there's no room named
after me what am I chopped liver you
know I hate that phrase no crystal has a
room crystal has a room he's my in my
generation all right Sinatra fine and
Billy Dee Williams Billy Billy which his
name and a great record disc jockey was
one of the great Billy I always been
mispronounce his name but he has a room
George Burns has a poker room go where's
my room then it hit me
automatically I said I know I and a good
I love Lenny Bruce a lot and I love a
lot of the old guys I want Lenny would
be so proud of me if I asked for this
I want the men's room named after me so
the men's room will be unveiled no [ __ ]
October 10th at the Fry's it's the
Richard Lewis John from forever the
whole thing yes a stall yeah all the
year and you can go on my Twitter line
and see a picture of the the toilet it's
gonna be no not the stole yeah jewel
where you go I gotta take a [ __ ] in
Lewis's toilet I'm so proud of them
that's better than getting a sandwich at
you know so ELISA
no they gave me what 20 years ago I had
his sandwich what I was doing to Jamie
Lee Curtis show
Edwyn Oh Mia people know you you know 30
million 40 million crazy it's it's nutty
yeah it's no wonder why people spent too
much drink too much to do too much cheat
too much you just feel like you're you
know you're you could do anything you
want
you can't I found that out fortunately
in time but I got a sandwich at the
stage deli which is no longer there and
I think if I'm not mistaken the Carnegie
Arnold yeah it's it just closes Jesus
crazy they're gonna put a Mormon
Tabernacle Choir buffet
Scientology celebrity senators I don't
know what they're gonna put there but I
had a sandwich at the stage and I opened
it are they mr. Lewis we got his
sandwich away Thanks very proud here's
the sandwich and again I'm not deeply
religious but I'm a proud Jew yeah
white bread mayonnaise baloney and
butter and I said I'm a Jew if I eat
this I'll become the Exorcist my head
will spin around I'll spit green pea
soup but everybody in this restaurant
they said mr. Lewis it's a great
sandwich we all eat it because you're
all Gentiles jews oniy butter and
mayonnaise and baloney and white bread
it's a curse on your family you're
kosher caterer dad must have been look
oh my god he would have been humiliated
yeah but so be it we got to do some
politics can we do a little bit
everything you want let's do a little
bit I did too much comedy no no I I
could I could do this all day yeah I
mean I really could but yours
you're not thought of I don't think
people think of you as particularly
political but I've heard you talk about
a little bit I don't know if that's
necessarily true because I'm not a I'm
not a political satirist yeah okay Mort
Sahl Lenny Bruce come to mind
not even lent you money you know and
there's and and and and and and Lewis
black they are that's that's their
that's their that's their sweet spot my
sweet spot which I found out was just
was was unraveling my psyche that's my
strength yeah
my strength is not to discuss wire why
we went to Iraq or not I can I have
thoughts about it and I like to channel
things through me and Irene here's an
example I wasn't a big fan of Bush at
all President Bush you know the last one
and so I here's what I would do and like
you know I didn't get I wouldn't do a
Lewis blacks thing that much I mean if I
was on an MSNBC show I would get a
little heavier cuz I'm a political
junkie so I somewhat know what I'm
talking about but it doesn't really
matter I'm one guy it doesn't matter
it's like let me just say there's all
these people scream it all day it
doesn't matter what they're saying no it
doesn't matter and particularly this
thing about President Trump did I say
president yeah
Trump's base the thirty six percent
thirty eight percent I you know I say
and I said this I was on the Melbourne
show the beat and I and he didn't
understand my point I wish he had but
he's a smart guy he was a good friend of
mine and I said 36 percent couldn't care
less if President Trump said locker up
punch someone in the face I'll get you
off you know I know I'm not that upset
about white supremacist or neo now you
know they don't care okay
I said but I Got News for you out of
that 38 percent not every one of that 38
percent are that crazy to be rooting for
white supremists
to take over or neo-nazis or you know
they're just not part of that 38 percent
and it bugged me so I told Ari I said
it'll all come down to voting and I said
I said the bottom line is this I said
I'm one guy it doesn't matter what I say
I got I want to vote I want to vote for
politicians that have you know my point
of view but not every politician I even
vote for as my point of view so you got
to be in a more general you know
but I'm certainly not gonna vote for
someone who says now look there's some
nice neo-nazis he's off my list you know
but he's also off the list of this 38%
base and it pisses me off that they lump
everyone that voted for Trump a lot of
people voted for Trump because he was a
celebrity they voted for him because the
the the government the Congress was was
was not working and he and and any any
and he had the right words you know he
didn't have a lot of words he doesn't
have a great vocabulary which brings me
back to Bush I don't have a great
vocabulary and I would always feel and
even though I didn't agree with on major
political theories of President Bush and
Cheney or Cheney whatever whomever I
really didn't you know I thought a lot
of it was was horrifying to me however I
would rather than be a hardcore social
satirist I would say you know I like
Bush his wife she's a librarian she's
sweet but can you imagine I mean I and
my wife mocks me and Larry David mocks
me when I like I said Ben Laden wants on
his TV instead of bin Laden says did you
say Ben Laden and he kept it in the show
and then I fortunately came up with a an
ad lib I went yeah Ben law and I buy my
search at Benoit there's like a forty
six straight and a good luckily yeah but
so what I would do a lot of the time is
in my own way say you know Bush
shouldn't be in control the country he's
not that variety as no as is working
vocabulary is non-existent and I can
just I feel so sorry for mrs. Bush she's
so sweet
and I can just see him coming out and I
used to do this thing coming out after
you used to be friends with the Prime
Minister of England who was the guy who
neglect Blair so he'd come out and they
had the two microphones and I did this I
actually did this it was like a little
bit of a bit and I'd say he'd come out
after after lunch and say we just had
the greatest then I would do Bush go oh
good then I had Blair go brunch brunch
brunch then I would do mrs. Bush go you
[ __ ] used I would have mrs. bush the
first lady put her husband down for me
that was my style yeah I was still
making a point
why is he president he's not see you
know not everyone's smart not that but
this guy's you know he he Lisi has to
listen to what's right he doesn't know
what's right so you know I would make
you know I'm not a hardcore political
satirist but I you know if I'm really
upset about something and you gotta know
something too when you go on stage and
you know this God knows you've been a
comic a long time as well of all the
other things you do admirably I might
add the thing is you know if I go on
stage and it's 2,000 people you know
this is about 25 percent who love bush
not because these might as father was a
Klansman or because he has a history of
racism in New York City which is all
true
by the way and it's not fake news and
all of that stuff you're talking Trump
Trump Trump yeah yeah but if I come out
and just tears Trump I'm gonna be
screamed at by fifteen or twenty percent
of the people so here's what I did and
I'm saying as I did it I'm sorry to
repeat it but I did a slight Trump joke
anti Trump joke on television last week
on Jimmy Kimmel show mm-hmm and I went
oh god I know I'm gonna alienate and
then I said I just came out I'm gonna
alienate three of you and that was my
way of saying that only three percent of
the audience gives a [ __ ] about this guy
that was just my lefty LEM I'm not even
a leftist I don't know what I am you're
an old-fashioned liberal that's I'm an
old-fashioned edible yeah that's what I
am you are I remember and I used to talk
about my parents when I was a kid
because you know we were this was only
only about 15 years after the Holocaust
you know and I would I had and we had a
and I was in kindergarten and my and I
told my mother who - my vote will I have
to vote for either Adlai Stevenson or
Dwight Eisenhower and she says Democrat
I think oh why she's
I had no idea what she was talking about
but now allegedly and have been more
than just allegedly Jews
you know I hate stereotypes you know
there's one bad landlord you know Trump
is a horrible landlord
you know it's documented just google his
landlord history in New York he was
racist he wouldn't he wouldn't even give
a paw it's just there it's just there he
has a lot of bad character defects you
know I don't know him well but he has
horrible character defects for me but my
parents didn't you know in terms of
politics you know I remember going to
see Ben Hur with my father in Radio City
and I said dad why the same thing I said
why had the Jews in the desert for 40
years why don't they want it can't they
get some sneakers they're not eating
they're praying for food to grow out of
sand he says because what joy and I
finally dawned on me the anti-semitism
that was crazy in America in the 20s
you know I saw on TV the other night
there was 50,000 Klansmen marching
through the streets of DC in the 20s in
the early 30s so you know that's what
life is so that's why I don't take it
set I don't take myself that seriously I
take myself seriously when I vote and I
take myself seriously like who I worked
for the Clinton for 10 years and gore
and they had me bring them on and and
and Secretary Clinton for tenth for
eight years because they were fans of
mine and they knew I was a political
junkie and I would have to go and bring
them on in front of ten fifteen thousand
people and I'll just say one this is
just something I have to tell you once
they have you it's like a once you're in
a production you're in a movie company
yeah you're a slave yeah you're a slave
I can't make it tomorrow
you're making it tomorrow we're suing
you yeah once you sign so once I was
with the DNC and working for it for
governor Clinton who became president
I was in so I was playing Washington I
was playing say knees in Chicago great
club by playing it for 40 years and I'll
be back there for the 40th anniversary
actually in January and I'm only saying
that because I love the club and of the
owners and I was on the hotel magazine
in every hotel room in Chicago Richard
Lewis because I went to my hotel room
and I there I was yeah and I went oh god
that's the DNC was in the hotel a lot of
hotels because they were it was 1996 and
Clinton and gore were gonna come to that
famous place where the where the boats
come in Chicago I can't think of the
name I'm it's it's a very famous heir
landmark in Chicago and they said
Richard you have to be at the pier the
naval pier Navy Pier for about three
hours until the it's locked down by the
you know the Secret Service and then you
introduced Gore and Clinton I go three
hours are you out of your mind
and I and I broke out in a tremendous
body rash I said on that I'm not gonna
be in front of the have a microphone
with a little pygmy mother oh yeah
young-kyu poor I don't like the first on
Yom Kippur that much in fact I don't
think I ever did I don't feel that belly
about it
I said I'm gonna talk about fear of
intimacy in front of 20,000 so I took a
cab to Gore's head of Gore's
communications head whatever he was and
I said I Got News for you you better get
somebody else a twenty to you because
they have like people working for the 20
year olds 18 year olds mr. Lewis were
here you're in town an army to do a
young girls voice but we want you to put
you sad that way to me I want you to
just do about four hours on intimacy
you're gonna miss it on Yom Kippur and
by the way yeah this is Russia shun oh
yeah I know you know kid that my dad
it was either temple or hang out with
Richard Louv happy holiday Jews I'm
happy new year so I said I'm not doing
it I said no way you get they don't know
these young kids you get jackson browne
you know
he's a Democrat you get Bonnie Raitt let
them sing for three hours get Pete
Seeger because he was still alive not me
yeah hey I'll tell you my grandpa showed
me wild you know you know so I got out
of it I don't even know why I brought it
up I'm sorry I've ruined the interview
we're all over the place here Louis
thanks very much for mocking me in front
of your audience you know for that
reason alone
oh I'm putting the glasses back on my
starter with the glasses and I'm gonna
end with the glass let's end with the
glasses that's there's there's something
look up 70 I got it you know I asked the
woman here you know when you get older
you think you don't think you're that
old you don't you don't want to thank
you that old how about that yeah so I
was at a restaurant yesterday and there
was two waitresses they were they could
have been my children easily to earth
21:22
I go do me a favor then and I named sure
they knew me I don't care I said do me a
favor I asked you a question and I said
how old do you think I am and they must
have it about 20 to 23 they were
waitresses restaurant and I said don't
say 90 you don't say 40 so one woman
said I I would say 66 Oh God and then
the other one said 64 I went I just get
out good you got to go I'll leave you a
nice tip yeah you got to get away from
me
and I went that's how that's what that's
what it's at I mean that's where it's at
if you ask someone 23 and you're 70 what
are they gonna say you're 41 right
unlike their grandfather holy Christ
yeah but you're doing Christ you know I
I wish you the best have come down ready
we were talking right before we started
taping but just a little bit about some
of the political stuff and you said to
me you know what what are you by the way
I'm sorry to interrupt you but I get
$12,000 every time I hold this up not on
YouTube ads I can tell you that much
yeah sure I'm sure
and I said you I'm an old school liberal
and you really were like well me too
yeah what does that mean to you because
that's one of the things my audience
talks about all the time that's sort of
what's happens if I'm in more oh no no
no
when I get your half more I'd have no I
get it
no because but it was what does that
mean to you like butts unless it's like
old school like what does because
because because back in the old days in
the 50s in the 60s there it wasn't split
up and so polarized there's so many
cultural subjects that divide Democrats
and even Republicans that it's it's
impossible to say I'm a Democrat I'm a
Republican
now I'm a leftist you know I'm a
socialist you know I'm a timer you know
I mean it's just too many what do you
call the topics that they talk about the
hot topics during campaigns I know you
know this I've just you know they're
cultural topics yeah but it's a name for
them when you know you know when they're
talking like pro-choice not throw choice
you know you don't know you don't know
either what the phrase is I mean just
there's just a list of all the things
it's not a list you know something I've
lost tremendous respect for you well
this is the there's the high we call him
hot tub no they're not hot yes there is
a phrase it there cause there's a word
someone on it so there's a word there's
a word for for a word for like cultural
topics that will will divide eBay Jewish
use okay there you go
how's that you know I'll give you a
b-plus yeah now they are wedges yeah so
there's so many major issues now yeah
back then it was just wedge lettuce you
want what do you want on a russian
dressing whoa Italian a little blue
cheese a little Poochie Donna yeah no
it's not good people touch blue cheese
would how many people with you guys you
and Larry all these comics Jerry is just
a Jewish thank you guys we can't don't
let your food you know people touch food
what's problem why can't someone touch
your food what to tell you this I put up
you don't want to know what I put ok
brought my own toilet at home every time
my wife my wife has her own business of
beauty melon do you think it's a great
business just to be a record a very
famous record producer not producer of
publisher and now she's not she's in a
health and beauty business and so she
sometimes I'll have and I'm like
I isolate night I don't like people
coming over my house she had 30 women
over the house and all I could think
about and I love women don't get me
wrong
with 30 behinds on my guest toilet and I
didn't say that to Joyce which is by the
way Joyce I've disgusted is there's one
of the worst names sexually you could
give to you'll never you know I was
never a hooker person I had girlfriends
yeah I didn't need hookers then and I
and I feel I feel hookers are important
I think they don't get there do well now
we got the quote from the episode we
always look for one line what's the line
you didn't think hookers got their due
Oh from this yeah that was the line yeah
but no that's gonna mean my wife's gonna
think I'm gonna go to that place in Reno
I got a blow job I don't need a free
blow job yeah I don't think bro lodged I
don't think you should charge for a blow
job
you never did the how about Amsterdam no
in all the years of easy years here is
right here's how hit my wife is yeah I
was a womanizer
consensually yeah I love women okay I
had the greatest time in my life and I
said I met my wife I had a great I have
a great time I mean we're getting older
now you know it's either intercourse or
my back goes out and I got to figure it
out but I love my wife and she's
beautiful and she's not half my age and
I'm you know I don't have to deal with
any of that crap anymore like you know I
did a joke a long time ago like what's
what was the joke it was when going out
with a 23 year old and I'm like 48 and I
would say what's Serpico and and she
would say that's a yeast infection you
know I couldn't take it
I couldn't take I used to put on I'll
admit something to you and we're good
finally my opener there's more there was
less wedge issues because now in 10
years we'll be more Hispanics more
blacks more Asians and this country will
not look like it did in 1960 so it's
going to be it's going to be a very
different political sit is already and
that's what I was trying to tell our REM
Elber I said people have to you know the
Asians have devoted
you know the the blacks have to vote you
know but you know the everybody everyone
you know the the Muslims have to vote
you vote for who you think is fair yeah
and and and moral and not anti-semitic
er you know I mean that's the only way
it's gonna happen you know you know and
what was so disgusting to me you know
and and I sure I was no one's perfect
you know all if you could look back at
all of all the presidents you know even
the guy you know for FDR who did so you
know III considered I think after y'all
went way too late to get involved in the
war you know Jews were being burned you
know I mean there's this books written
about it while America slept he was an
amazing president but there was a it was
this whole country was anti-semitic half
of it you know there was 50,000 Clanton
marching down the streets of DC in the
30s for Christ's sake you know listen if
your grandfather if you live in Alabama
okay
and by the way the Southern Poverty Law
Center to me is one of the most heroic
institutions of any effort I haven't I
haven't when I had no money yeah
when I had no money and I was a comic
and I found out about the Southern
Poverty Law Center in Mobile I believe
it's in Mobile and that guy who started
it and I fighting the Klan the heroism
with this guy in the balls that this guy
had and not and fearless I said I have
to join you know I got a little card and
I said I'll pay eight dollars a month if
you send me a card and I was so proud of
that Southern Poverty Law Program well
without putting into holding they've
really taken a shift in a way that's not
good these days I mean they have this
tell me tell you they have a crazy list
of anti Muslim extremists including
ayaan Hirsi Ali who I think is the
greatest feminists and humans right
activists we have on earth so what was
is over there G Gabriel so they've taken
an I think I know this because I knew
that you were gonna try to embarrass me
total and I was well you don't want to
talk about what Lee Majors catching 54
I'll go tell me so what is the twist no
say it's a slight twist are you putting
them down for a slight twist no well
it's a major what if I think I cou they
they don't want us they don't want to
stand up for white supremists who bring
weapons what about that they also have
their own problems right now they're
also backing someone like Linda Sarsour
who's pretty pretty terrible but I don't
have a call a saw what did you just say
to me
Linda SARS why are we getting so serious
yeah tell me about this other pop you're
right what you're back no no I want to
know about the Southern Poverty Law
Center what they have what are some of
the few things that are aggravating so
the main thing yeah they they basically
they're not sort of where it used to be
about equal rights for everyone it is
now become very politicized to the left
so they've taken people who I know three
people at a show are good decent human
beings why do you think they don't like
them in the case of or hate them in the
case of these three people I've labeled
anti-muslim extreme it's it's because
they talk about Islam honestly I on who
underwent female genital mutilation and
was going to be forced into an arranged
marriage and had her French how do you
think they would talk to you right now
not me but how would they debate you
they would say that well they
unfortunately they don't make the
distinction between talking about Islam
which is a set of ideas versus Muslims
who are people and you can talk about
ideas without discriminating against
people like you could rag on the Old
Testament all day long nobody's going
Lewis is an anti-semite
you know right and they have a
unfortunately because it's become so
politicized they have trouble making
that I would need to do but I'm but I'm
no I I've heard this yeah I would have
to do far more research to have a really
an intelligent conversation tell you
about it yeah what you're saying no from
back then I felt quite diminished quite
frankly my penis went inside for a
second but that's okay yeah no I'm not
even disagreeing with you I just need to
know more information that's all though
people don't do that too often these
days right just say wow I don't know
something there just shoots no it's not
that I know what's going on about the
leftist and to left and not left and
and this and and and not and not
believing and not just sticking up for
the human being and the mutilation part
I know all about this but I need to know
the the legitimate facts and the debates
on both sides before I can make an
honest you know and honest to have give
you an honest answer about how I feel
yeah but that those three things aside
which are big asides for you yeah what
they have done for the last 50 years
fighting the Ku Klux Klan I mean come on
absolutely I historically I'm with you
I'm with you yeah I mean I mean you know
are you gonna go down there and and just
up and you know put on put a camera
underneath the sheet what I was going to
say was that I used to talk about here's
the way you asked me about being not too
political yeah here's the way I would I
would channel things politically I'd say
anyway
I'd say if you're a kid and you're great
a great pitcher and you're at 11 years
old
all-star worthy and you live in Alabama
your grandfather was a Klansman your
father was raised by his grandfather and
he's uh he hates Jews and he hates
blacks and he may or may not be a
Klansman okay
let's say he is just for sake of this
notion and he has an and he has a and he
has a World Series Little League game in
Mobile okay and he's gonna and the kid
he's 11 years old you know he hasn't
been infiltrated with all this crap and
we and with all this the left and the
right and the middle and racism a nice
M&D just wants to hit he just wants to
pitch a no-hitter
he's pure he's pure this is what kills
me it's the children are getting so
[ __ ] over they're getting [ __ ] over
by these by these antiquated crazy
anti-semitic racist ideas now what you
just mentioned about what you were
dissing a disagreement with the pallino
with the Southern Poverty Law Center I'm
gonna do research about that but I'm
still not going to take the track it's
not going to detract what they've done
there had been heroic to me but here's
the kid the kids putting on a little
league uniform okay
and he has to get to the games a dad you
got it you're gonna come to the game he
says I can't I
I want to lynch a black man he wouldn't
say black man okay and I'm gonna burn a
temple so I might be late so this kid
hears this he has no idea what he's
talking about but I guarantee you when
he gets into high school and he knows
more about what his father's talking
about there's a really good chance he's
going to be a Klansman mm-hmm and that
to me is the saddest part of this whole
world demise
you know demise the right word that is
falling apart it's because children
aren't getting a the education is so
poor in this country it's just so
unfortunate and you know and I know what
I really like and you would probably
appreciate this I saw a guy on the news
the other day who was a white supremists
and he just wrote a book about I don't
know his name and he was on when he was
plugging his book and for a guy who was
a white supremists to take a turn and
realize how [ __ ] up that was and how
despicable and horrifying a was and to
be a holocaust denier and to hold the
whole bit and then start an organization
you know a charity to try to go into
these organizations and try to save one
person it's like I'm a drug addict and
an alcoholic I always will be okay
but when I can save well if I help one
person and I have and I'm not boasting
about it who were near death who were
now sober for years that makes
everything worth it that makes my
sobriety more important than me being
sober because I'm saving someone else
so in this guy who was a white
supremacist can you know put on a
uniform and put a camera on and tape and
then show this guy what he's really part
of and then the guy comes back with him
and says what was I thinking that to me
is really heroic so you know I'm all
over the place again but I just feel
badly for the children that you know
you've seen this now I'm not just gonna
be one-sided but you've seen you've seen
it and I know that the PLO and the Jude
and
and building this and not building this
and this and it is left in the right and
I there's issues everywhere yeah there's
issues everywhere okay but when you see
tapes and and and intimate and is it
fair for me to say this I don't know is
there fair for me to say that does not
that many tapes of young three or four
year old Jewish children saying let's
kill every Palestinian because you know
you've seen those tapes or the young
Palestinians screw the Jews you know
they hate us we hate them now I'm not
suggesting it's not you know an
occasional bad Jewish family that might
do this over dinner right but this is
the thing that this it's I you know I
feel so horrified for those Palestinian
children they just want to play soccer
man yeah you know and so you know if you
ask me if I'm political I am political
but I'm political in the way I can if I
can express it in my own language you
know I can't express it like you would
express it well like Lewis black or like
Lenny did or like you know or you know
or even we know Pryor was political he
was you know he got so disgusted with
comedy he took a year off and you know
he was you know he's had to figure out
like like we didn't even talk about Dick
Gregory here's a guy who was a hero to
me here's a black guy who back then who
marched with Martin Luther King and who
was playing white audiences and was so
funny and so brilliant that he could do
jokes about it about racism and get
audiences to laugh but not at him but
with him and that to me you know Dick
Gregory there was way underrated as you
know he should have you know this guy
should have gotten a many of many awards
many of many awards I won't get an award
I will get an award for playing Richard
Lewis as himself by himself for himself
and only for himself and for Larry David
and of course for you it's the only
reason I did Kurt this year he won
because I didn't do cause he sure you
wouldn't have had me on and you were
number 40 on that
forget 244 listen man we could do this
all day
truly you know I know that because I've
heard you talk about this before the the
piece of sort of linking to the people
that matter to you that have influenced
you and all of those things I know how
valuable that is to you and you
absolutely are one of those people to me
and that's why I hunt you I literally I
feel like I hunted you for the last two
years it's very you know it's hard for
you know here's the difference you asked
me something before why I have more
inner peace or it seemed to be because
what you just said means a lot to me and
I didn't automatically go no no no
you're right that's what I used to do
yeah but I have earned the right to
accept that feeling that you have about
me and that's what given me some peace
it's not arrogance and it's just an
acceptance of that I had a goal in life
when I was 20 and and I got someone of
your ilk to appreciate that and that
means the world to me yeah I feel like
we're supposed to do one of these at the
end right did you wash it's basically
clean though all right thanks for having
me all right well sum up we didn't talk
that much about it but the new season of
Curb starts on Sunday October 1st on HBO
and you can get tickets for Richards
current stand-up tour tracks of Cocoa
Beach Florida with another recovering
drug addict Artie Lange October 7th then
I'm going to New York the 13th and 14th
the Caroline's and then I'll be in
helium and the week of the 20th in
Philadelphia and that's enough and try
the veal I mean and enjoy the view
Richard Lewis thank you
[Music]
you